welcome back for another episode of
vintage egyptologist today we're going
to be talking about
scents perfumes and incense
in ancient egypt
[Music]
[Applause]
and our sponsor today is none other
than penn halligan's a company with a
storied history going back to 1870
and the holder of two royal warrants
the first in 1903
the reason why i want to begin with the
concept of royal warrants
is because of king hotshepza
who not only used incense as a way
to legitimize her kingship
but also dispatched an expedition to put
to fetch incense frankincense
and myrrh and commemorated that as
one of the signature achievements of her
reign
king hatshepsut ruled between 1473
and 1458 bce
she was the daughter of a king tutmos
the first
and a wife of another king tupmos the
second
upon the death of topmost the second hat
shepherd essentially takes over as
regent ruling while tutmos iii
is a child however seven years into this
arrangement
she actually declares herself king very
possibly because she had
a very important ritual role the god's
wife of a moon
and also could trace back her lineage
to both the kings and the queens of the
late
seventeenth dynasty hatshepsut uses
some interesting means to legitimize
her kingship including a fascinating
cycle of reliefs
at her temple on the west bank of thebes
now called gerald bahri we call these
scenes
the divine birth cycle
these images and texts claim that the
god al moon
is actually hachipso's father and this
goes back
to the very beginnings of egyptian
kingship where the king was believed to
be
the earthly incarnation at first the god
horus
and soon after the sun god ra by the
time
of the middle kingdom the god of moon of
thebes who then becomes the imperial god
of the new kingdom is closely associated
with kingship but hot shepherd's reign
is the first time that we have these
images
preserved in this way with these
hieroglyphic annotations
so how does a moon engendering the
future king hot shepherd
relate to perfume in this scene
we see a moon on the left his
crown is mostly damaged but we know from
many many other examples of our moon
that he would have been wearing a crown
with two tall
ostrich plumes and on the right we see
queen ahmosa who is hot shepherd's
mother
a ahmosa and amun's legs are crossed
and he is giving the sign of life
both to her nostrils and into her palm
these are subtle ways in which the
egyptians
express intimacy the hieroglyphic text
is a bit more explicit quote
words spoken by amin raw lord of the
thrones
of the two lands foremost of his private
apartment after he made his
transformation
into the majesty of this her husband
tutmos
given life so that is how
aman rey gains entry into the queen's
bedroom
he transforms into the king
into topmos the first the hieroglyphic
text then continues
he a moon found her
the queen as she was resting in the
interior of the palace
she awakened because of the divine aroma
and she smiled before his majesty
so what gives the god away what
indicates to the queen
that it is a moon and not her husband
topmost the first
is how he smells after the
actual divine conception occurs we read
how quote
love of him coursed through all of her
limbs
and the palace was inundated with divine
aroma
every one of his sense was from
point and this topped him punt
is fascinating because that is the
origin
of so many of the materials that the
ancient egyptians
used to create their own
sense it is difficult to pinpoint
exactly
the ancient location of point
however we know from hot chipset's
reliefs
that she dispatched a maritime
expedition she had ships built
dismantled taken across the eastern
desert probably on the wadi hamamat road
reassembled and launched south along the
red sea
and we have fabulous depictions of the
sorts of
fish that the sailors encountered
when the egyptian expedition brought
back from
point unto you trees trees
that would produce the incense that
would be burnt upon the altars
of temples throughout egypt
we know that by doing this
was fulfilling the promises that she
made
to her divine father amu
the ancient egyptians had several
different words for incense
the main word is sinnetter which
literally means
to make divine so the root nature
meaning god
or naturee divine with a causative
s prefix thus to make
divine another word for incense the
egyptians use
is coppet and that root
refers to smoke or burning
and it's really interesting that the
ancient egyptian word
coppet thus has the same etymology
of our word perfume which goes back to
latin meaning from
smoke because the easiest way to release
a scent in antiquity was through
burning in addition to temple ritual
burning incense for the gods
the ancient egyptians also used scents
during celebrations and this is where we
get that concept
of the perfume infused
wax cones that people would place
on top of their wigs during giant
festival celebrations
the ceramicin tomb painting is a
brilliant example
of how ancient egyptian art is full
of scents we can see
the scented wax cones that both the man
and his wife are wearing but we also see
floral collars beneath their chairs
and another great indication of scent
are the lotus blossoms also decorating
the women's wigs so when we see art
like this it's not just an indication
of the visual richness of a
festival celebration or hear a funerary
banquet but the images themselves
are redolent with the sweet smells
of the ancient nile valley
when the ancient egyptians made perfumes
what they were actually creating were
scented
onigins and oils because at that point
in antiquity distillation had not been
invented
meaning that you could not have
alcohol-based perfumes
as we have today and has certainly
existed
by the middle ages but there's even an
egyptian connection here
because it appears that the process of
distillation
which required a certain type of
glassware
was actually created by a female
alchemist who lived in alexandria in the
first
couple of centuries ce maria of
alexandria
the alchemist thus set the stage
for later developments of distillation
and perfumes
that we can enjoy today such as the
remarkable
historical and trade routes collections
at penn halligan's in future episodes
we're going to dive deeper into the
ancient egyptian origins of
alchemy going beyond the work of maria
of alexandria
and zozomos of panopoulos into how
metallurgists and minors of the pharonic
era
set the intellectual stage for the deep
alchemical reflections
that we see in later authors